[Music]  we can't undo the lies we had to tell  girls  that's just the way it is  i'm finn  then ahead  dennis's son  how do we know that you are what you say  you are  he's dangerous but  you need to be very careful  i knew my dad he wasn't a murderer i  knew did it  that's what i'm trying to figure out  we need to stick together  we give him nothing we tell him nothing  you want some help  finn  this feels personal  oh man  i'm sorry  i've always been on the outside  outside looking in  doing this  i want you  i'm doing this for my dad  i don't want to stop until i find out  what you did to him because i know it  was you've found  it's always you  from now on we'll tell each other the  truth  [Music]  you